please will you welcome director Damien
Chazelle start Emma Stone and composer
Justin Hurwitz now look this goes back
for the two of you Damien and Justin
this goes back way beyond even whiplash
doesn't it because you were at college
together and I believe at college you
worked on something but possibly in some
ways was kind of a precursor to this
because it was a documentary musical
yeah I mean we I mean Justin I met I
think it was like the first week or so
no it's very early on playing in a band
together and we you know I was playing
drums he was playing piano pretty
quickly I think we realized that you
know we weren't going to be rock stars
and and shared this love of film and
especially you know different ways that
you can marry music and film and around
the same time I was you know as a
student I was making a lot of
documentaries that was kind of a
documentary focused program a lot of
cinema verite type movies and and then
every night I would go to the film
archive on campus and just watch old
movies and I've been a movie buff my
whole life but that was around the time
when I really fell in love with musicals
especially especially classic Hollywood
musicals from the 30s and 40s so I think
I don't know I think it was kind of in a
way the sort of the mix of kind of what
I was doing what I was shooting and what
I was watching that kind of got both of
us thinking you know got me thinking and
then both of us thinking how could you
do a musical in that style but ground it
and sort of invest it with as much
realism as possible especially as much
kind of city realism kind of shooting on
the streets and and shoot stuff that you
used to shoot on back Lots in kind of
real city locations with real residents
of the city so that led to our first it
was basically my senior thesis is as a
film student and you wanted it to be
your senior thesis as a music studio
music department wouldn't they reject my
thesis so and I think both of us got an
incomplete on it actually
well we both left school and just
disappeared and went to LA so so yeah so
we were failures and
and but it you know it was it was the
seed I think of this the idea that
eventually led to those yeah it's that
very mixture isn't it Emma between
talking about that
sort of what keeping it real but at the
same time all that sort of idea of the
mid-century musicals and the kind of
Golden Age musicals when you were when
this was first sort of put to you as an
idea that mixture of sort of the
naturalism that makes it so contemporary
and all the old references I mean was
that was that how they described it to
that was absolutely the intention from
the very beginning and I had many
questions about how that would be
achieved because on the page it's such
an incredible and ambitious and
interesting idea but on the day it's
sometimes difficult to calibrate how you
will marry those two ideas so yes but
from the very beginning it was it was
clear that Damian wanted to present
something that was very natural that
wasn't this kind of the way we're
singing and dancing you know it's
grounded in reality it's you're not
fooling anyone into thinking these are
like these incredibly lifelong
technically you know fantastic singers
and dancers but we we had the thing
thank you but there was a you know but
we had this great this great amount of
rehearsal time and and yeah that was
that was definitely the intention that
those two things would you know be
cohesive in the film and just with the
music because I mean very early on I'd
started to think oh you know Jacques
Demy Michel a girl that kind of that's
like sort of you know falling
immediately quite poignant even though
visually it looks so different because
episode that opening is so big and
ambitious
so is that is it is it has a kind of
French feel all the way yeah I mean
that's that's been an inspiration I was
I was trying to compose something that
wouldn't sound like LeGrande trying to
orchestrate something that wouldn't
sound like that but it's I mean they're
definitely approaches like the way
lagron marries the jazz rhythm section
to the huge orchestration so you have
you know piano bass drums playing it
like jazz players then you have a huge
orchestration that's all on the page no
improv so the way the improv is married
orchestration is something that I took
from him and then just the way that I
mean he puts a lot of dissonance into
his into his orchestrations and also
just in his harmonies and I do that as
well I'd like to think I was using a
slightly different harmonic palette and
you know the melodies are a little
different than his and that it sounds
like my own thing but there's definitely
the way he uses the orchestra in the way
he uses kind of dissonance in his
compositions is something that I
definitely was inspired by I know and
all of that the sort of the melody that
plays those kind of distances and the
way that the music and the mood of the
music plays into this kind of
contemporary and yet slightly nostalgic
feeling at the same time is that is that
something you could constantly keeping
is yeah I mean I guess it was I mean a
lot of what was to me really beautiful
when I first saw some of the ejecta me
movies was was maybe sure opened my eyes
a little bit to what musicals could
express emotionally because I think
sometimes we have the sort of
preconception that that musicals are you
know sort of a OneNote genre and you
know that that that that everything is
kind of at 11:00 you know that either
it's pure joy all the time or it's kind
of you know operatic tragedy or it's you
know it's it's somewhere kind of it's
like one or the other and and the thing
that I found about especially the jack
to me musicals but honestly also I think
a lot of the great older American
musicals I think not you know we've kind
of America's sort of lost this tendency
but I think a lot of that great older
Hollywood musicals like meet me in st.
Louie and movies like that it's just
they expressed kind of the rhythms of
everyday life and and a vision of the
world where some things work out some
things don't where where emotions can be
sort of multi multi-layered a little bit
you know happy can be mixed with sad
melancholy can be laced with hope and it
was this kind of wonderful marriage I
guess of the way life feels with with
the grandeur and the pomp and the magic
of of what only movies can do you know
and I think that was kind of really the
at least emotionally it was the real
attraction in May of those movies and
and certainly kind of an inspiration for
us you know on all levels both with
music acting and all the departments you
know the craft departments of trying to
try to have the movie be somewhat
emotionally have a foot in both worlds a
little bit I was it to challenge what
I'm when you're literally soaring above
wires or whatever it is it is it a
challenge then to kind of keep it real
to keep it spontaneous because I offer
all you do those things have to be
rehearsed so many times well it I mean
because we had these three months just
spend together and to be doing our dance
rehearsal or singing rehearsal or
rehearsing on wires as you're saying in
the planetarium I think that was where
we sort of hashed out how we would go
about making this I mean what how
natural it would be how subtle we could
make it or how much it needed to be sort
of expressed in our faces and and I
think by the time we were shooting it
felt like we could just sort of let it
go and and that most of the time it
would feel relatively grounded even when
we were you know being hoisted into
space to sort of nail down in our in our
extensive rehearsal process which we
were so lucky to have and and it begins
of course really big it begins you know
you've got CinemaScope and you make the
most of it straightaway and but as a
film it kind of comes down and gets more
intimate as it goes yeah yeah I mean
yeah I mean I guess that was sort of the
idea from the outset was to try to I
mean begin with a bang in the sense that
you know also especially as we learned
during the six years of trying to get
the movie made not everyone loves
musicals as much as much as we do and so
I feel like you kind of bow it to the
audience especially these days to be as
upfront as possible about what the what
the movie is gonna be you know allow
people the opportunity to flee the
theater in the first five minutes if
they need to and but also a little bit
you know that idea of kind of you begin
with the world
and you begin with a sort of world
establishing number and then I mean
actually everything kind of almost feels
more natural as a result after that
number is part of the idea of really not
just beginning with a big number but
beginning with arguably our biggest
number in the whole movie and at least
until the end you know having a little
bit above this none of this none of that
you know there was a little bit the the
arc that we kind of mapped out for
ourselves and then I think it really but
I mean going back I guess a little bit
to what Emma was saying also about you
know grounding things I mean I think
that you know for me as the sort of
lucky filmmaker that got to work with
her and Ryan and the rest of the cast
that was part of what was astounding to
me was that you know by necessity like
any musical this was a movie that was
very pre designed in many ways you know
and and with long very carefully
choreographed takes even when it wasn't
a musical number and and all sorts of
things that would kind of hem in the
actors normally and and she and Ryan I
think are able to or were able to make
still somehow make stuff feel completely
spontaneous and still invest it with
their own quirks and idiosyncrasies and
make it feel completely sort of natural
and grounded at every moment in a way
that I remember just consistently
surprised me and my DP Lena Sangren
every day of shooting was you know that
we were kind of it felt like we were
getting at something through through you
and through Ryan that was as truthful as
we wanted even amidst all the the kind
of bells and whistles of you know in the
machinery of a big musical I mean so
many people say they don't like musicals
people like music like films I think I
think the I think the thing about I
think I think there's there's that
there's I mean there's a few things with
musicals I mean one I think it was sort
of what I was saying about you know this
idea that musicals have to be have to be
all in your face all the time you know
this kind of conception of musicals that
I really think is is it you know has
come about in the past few decades when
most musicals have been adapted from
Broadway the idea of the original
musical conceived for the screen is just
not the norm in Hollywood anymore and
even you know the rare occasions that
musicals are made they're always
adapted from something and and but it
used to be you used to have this kind of
almost conversational approach to
singing and dancing I think we may be
mistakenly think of the old MGM musicals
as these kind of pure technical
showcases and of course in many cases
they were some of those dancers are some
of the greatest dancers to ever exist
but but I think what actually makes
those movies really work is you know if
you look at Fred and Ginger you know I
find myself really looking at Ginger
Rogers face and how she acts those
numbers I think she's actually the real
in a way the real sort of as much the
magic in those numbers as Fred Astaire
his feet its Ginger Rogers face and how
she grounds every moment in the subtlest
most nuance most timeless way possible
without saying a single thing in queues
you emotionally to all the ups and downs
of of what's otherwise a very artificial
kind of circumstance and you look at how
some of those you know Gene Kelly or
Fred Astaire would sing and how how a
number like dancing in the dark and in
bandwagon how it just kind of seamlessly
grows from walking through a park to
dancing and then kind of back again to
you know they sort of dance their way
back to it into a carriage and there's
just such a beautiful kind of
seamlessness to those movies where as
where's the thing now we think of
musicals a little more as a
stop-and-start kind of medium where it's
like dialogue and then and then and then
the numbers exist off in this other
corner I think we kind of liked that
someone older idea of having everything
feel like one continuous flow where
numbers just kind of grow more
organically so the transitions were
something that we were really it was
part of why we didn't cut a lot why we
did long takes and it was to try to make
it feel seamless I mean those kind of
long takes does that increase the
pressure or is that me yeah makes it
harder for ya yeah but I like it at this
point I think I like I like that kind of
I really do I strangely like that sort
of technical pressure it feels very
theatrical when you're doing something
in one take I like having to remember
where to go and if in some ways it gets
you out of your head because there is
something for you to focus on so you get
to sort of be free within it with enough
rehearsal
so I didn't mind it I'm going to open it
up to questions from you I really
enjoyed it thank you very much indeed
I wondered if mo like the character Mia
went to see was it rebel without of
course did you go and study any classic
musicals sort of as your mood board for
the getting ready for the character I
watched sing him in the rain again
definitely watched Fred and Ginger quite
a bit top hat was a big reference for us
and and and bandwagon and you know these
kind of classic films but also Damian
screened the umbrellas of Cherbourg for
us as a cast and crew we all sat on the
dance room floor where we were
rehearsing every day and it was
projected onto the wall and we ate pizza
and we watched umbrellas and I had never
seen it before and that of course was
was hugely inspiring to see because it
had what he was describing and this sort
of that jacked me sense of there was
this beautiful subtlety and an a
heartbreak to to that and obviously they
sing every line of that film so it was
startling at first but it was really it
was really special to see I was curious
about the casting of Emma and and Gotha
and Ryan Gosling
they had I don't know if it what
happened what I think made it so special
is the chemistry they had such fantastic
chemistry on stage and I wondered if you
did any of the casting of the two of
them together saw them together before
you made your decision to cast them well
I was I mean yeah in many ways again I
just felt like the lucky the lucky
filmmaker behind the camera when
whenever you know that they were
together I when when when I first
started writing this script and Justin
first started writing the music about
six years ago I think your first movie
with Ryan had had you know Ed either
just come out crazy stupid love it
either just come out or was kind of
brewing and before even that I'd loved
both Emma and Ryan individually as
performers but certainly kind of I think
the more we worked on this movie the
more the idea of them together felt kind
of wonderful but it also felt a little
bit like a pipe dream because we
Justin and myself we were kind of ads
outside the industries you can possibly
ket while being in LA and and certainly
felt that way trying to get this movie
made and pitching an original jazz
musical you know as former college
roommates saying we'll do it all and
yeah not didn't excite the money people
so so it actually I mean you know things
went through a few permutations in terms
of both financing and casting and and it
wasn't until you know several years into
it just and I went off and made whiplash
which I think it was kind of during the
release of that that I first met Ryan
first met Emma I think I began by
pitching Emma on the project when when
you were doing cabaret on Broadway and
then Ryan I'd met you know independently
and and he and I started talking about
the movie as well and it suddenly it
became very kind of organically suddenly
became a realistic proposition for the
first time that maybe they would not
only do it but do it together I think at
a certain point you guys also you must
have talked behind the scenes a little
bit behind my back No so again it was
very much it felt like that kind of one
of the biggest lucky moments for the
movie after years of feeling like it
would never get made and feeling like we
were victims of bad luck we'd almost get
there and then not it was that kind of
thing when it when it actually they came
together on the film it felt like oh
thank god actually it didn't happen
before because this is how it was meant
to be when people were I mean okay
people are nervous of musical funding
people a nervous of musicals but was
there anything that they wanted to
change I mean what was it they couldn't
oh yeah all of the music all of the
music
they were quite yeah and I think they
wanted well certainly the ending also
was not was kind of a bummer for people
they didn't you know they wanted them to
get married and ride off into the sunset
I think yeah it was I think oh yeah
those were the two main the two main
things and then just jazz being a pret
president at all was just kind of even a
reference to Jay one reference to jazz
is too much
what reference to many no thank you for
fabulous films a second time I've seen
it
but um what struck me the second time
around especially with the opening scene
was it it was a triumph of diversity and
it just hit me in the face how wonderful
it was to gather America it's just a
comment thank you
yeah it was it was funny how like I mean
obviously we we wrote this and you know
and shot it and everything at a slightly
different time in America it feels new
you know it wasn't that long ago but it
feels now like a totally different
America so yeah now it feels that the
world has kind of gone down the toilet
bowl a little bit oh I I like to think
actually that that you know musicals can
can you know I mean I've done some
thinking about the history musicals
obviously they came of age during the
Depression and whatnot you know and this
idea that certainly this movie presents
a somewhat idealized vision of you know
the world or what the world can be you
know the idea of but but it but it does
feel like somehow weirdly got maybe at
least for us more relevant than ever the
idea of like you know valuing things
like art and love and and you know just
kind of chasing dreams even though they
seem unrealistic to kind of not give up
hope at least at least that's kind of
something that has felt almost more
resonant for us at least on this side of
the aisle you know then it even did
before somebody will be writing that
thesis weren't they twenty years down
the line and 120 years
you know the beginning of the Trump here
and there oh great as you say like the
gold-diggers movies you know it's right
right yeah we all go I had now you can
see all those things well it's weird how
sometimes I mean I'll digress a little
bit of hold myself off but the just the
the I mean I I've been such a fan of
kind of classic Hollywood the sort of
Hollywood studio system Golden Age era
and what's so fascinating about those
movies is that you know we think that
movies got more realistic afterwards you
know and that everything about old
Hollywood is whether it's musicals or
westerns or whatnot was all very kind of
Shawn on sets and fake and you know etc
the acting style was very kind of not
what it is now and yet I think those
movies actually say so much about you
know as historical documents and about
the society that produced them and
sometimes totally as counterpoint you
know friend and Ginger dancing a
drawing-rooms well the country was
suffering during the Depression but
there's this really poignant I think
relationship with those movies between
history and and the movies that makes
them more than just escapism that makes
them kind of something more to me more
substantial so I think that's in a way
was the tradition that I think musicals
can be a part of that you know we wanted
to be a bargain
bit cheeky two questions Emma can you
talk about your own similarities with
the struggles if there are any in Mia's
career and can you also talk about how
this is for Damien how this your vision
of the cinematography what stage you
came in because obviously the camera
angles and the lighting it's quite
pivotal in telling the story so just how
they're all formed and you know your
collaboration on that thank you very
much yeah well I could relate to every
experience that Mia has in the movie you
can't say that with every character that
seems to be a question you know how do
you relate to your characters like a lot
quite a lot I LA when I was 15 and
started auditioning and got a couple
things here and there and I my my first
actual film role was about three years
in so in that time period there were
quite a few auditions which I think
ultimately you're lucky if you're
getting a lot of auditions it doesn't
feel good at the time that you're being
rejected on such a constant basis but
it's so much better than being ignored
and not even seen that you know in some
ways that the audition sequences were
kind of fun and cathartic and you know
exciting to explore again and the thing
that actually struck me and on a deeper
level was when Mia decides after her
one-woman show and really putting all
her vulnerability out there to go home
was the tough part because that element
is that never goes away I don't think
it's sort of you know those lulls and
those times where you feel like maybe
you are delusional
for being a creative person or trying to
make things how that ebbs and flows and
how up and down that can be but I had a
casting director who reminded me of the
casting director in the film and I
auditioned for her throughout that
three-year period often and I would
never get the part but she would keep
calling me in and then one day she
called me and she said will you come in
on a Saturday I'm just gonna put you on
tape for this movie and I really have a
good feeling about this I think it might
work out and it was super bad which was
my first movie and it changed everything
for me getting to do that film so it was
so interesting also to kind of revisit
the idea that these things that seem
like rejection and I think this is for
everything in life not just actors
auditioning because for many things
these things I feel like these horrible
kind of rejections in the moment or
things not working out ultimately can
lead to something that is far better
than what the path looked like it could
be originally so anyway yeah I relate to
Mia oh well yeah I mean there's a soul
eNOS our DP was I mean it was a gift to
work with him he I had I mean yeah I was
it was important from the outset that
the camera be a character in the movie
and
I think probably the first concrete
thinking I did about how the movie would
be shot was thinking about how the
dancing would be shot and just that I
wanted to shoot it in longer takes often
head to toe trying to kind of take the
long take model of Old Hollywood but
tried it trying to three-dimensional
eyes it even more do stuff with the
camera that you couldn't do as easily
back then so especially like the opening
number as an example of the kind of you
know choreography spilling out the edges
of the frame that I kind of I think also
thought a lot of you know it's a weird
example but thinking of Raging Bull you
know the way that boxing movies had
always stayed outside the ring before
Raging Bull for the most part you know
just to kind of give you a sense of the
geography and that's just the way it was
done and and the big innovation of that
movie was to put the camera in the ring
and so the idea of sometimes we don't do
it in every number but often putting the
camera in the middle of the number and
letting it kind of discover the number
as it would swirl around it that was
like the first I think concrete
discussion and then leanness and I you
know through talking decided okay if
that's gonna be how we filmed the dance
then it should inform how we film
everything else cuz we didn't want that
stop-and-start feel again where the
dance would be filmed completely
differently than everything else so I
think that's what turned the whole movie
what in a way until long longer take
very carefully blocked choreographed
movie where I mean I think you know you
guys you know Ryan none of the rest of
the cast
you know the choreography and blocking
was almost I think as precise if I
remember four four not you know four
dialogue scenes as it was four dancing
scenes even though it had to seem
completely spontaneous and natural so I
think it was a fun process we had I mean
the unsung hero I think was a Steadicam
operator that we had re Robbins who was
just a beast I mean he just he's like
this will tell you everything about him
he has tattoos of cameras on his arms
here or kink on his left arm or the
cameras that he is saved as in like
they've almost fell and he caught them
and and then he has tattoos of cameras
he dropped here just to so far but if he
like ever drops another camera three so
if he drops a fourth camera today you'll
get that tattooed like it's that's how
he lives his life behind a camera and
you need that kind of psychotic to do
there's scenes like this cuz he was he
was a champ and just did everything he's
the dancer you don't see really I
thought I was the last person who ever
painted a glass matte painting but
apparently I'm wrong my question isn't
why because I know why it's it's where
though and also did you have any issues
with the availability of any of the
optical processing so we it's funny so I
I had I had this dream of having you
know a certain amount of optical matte
painting and this I mean wound up just
being really just highlighted in that
one Paris shot you know at the end and
so I talked very early on with David
Wasco our production designer of who do
you know you know who who is around who
you know we were shooting in LA yeah and
so the so so this guy yeah it was this
guy I mean maybe you know I'm Rocco
Jaffray who's la-based who used to I
mean like a lot of these you know a lot
of matte painters you know now he does a
lot of digital work they used to do a
lot of the traditional matte paintings
and you know I think it was the first
such call he'd gotten in a very long
time so he was just like he was ready to
paint anything for us and he and he just
yeah I mean he has his own kind of
makeshift studio basically at his place
you know and he works with with an
associate with an assistant and and but
they you know they pretty much shot in
the in the old fashioned optical way and
kind of you know over the course of I
think a day or so just doing the move a
bit by bit and then sort of animating it
but it was done completely you know
completely analog both the matte
painting and miniature that he had built
and it was so I mean was one of my like
most fun experiences it was kind of
somewhat deep imposed by the time that
was finished going to his studio and
visiting it because it's I mean it's
just this giant gorgeous painting of
Paris and actually the the big direction
I had to always constantly give them was
to make it worse because initially his
painting was so good I mean you know I'm
sure you in the same way all the great
matte painters you're trained to make it
photo real and it was so good that
actually I wanted to feel the paint a
little bit and I and it just felt like
it was either gonna look like
photography or digital so I kept
actually I kept having to push him the
only thing I ever had to push him with
was to sort of thicken up the brush
and screw up things a little bit and and
actually make the painting less
technically perfect in order for you to
actually feel any of the pain that's how
good he was ironically but it was it was
amazing to work with him yeah his Ryan
played piano was that him playing
because he was brilliant and do you have
to practice always he a natural pianist
please now please now he took years in
piano lessons six days a week for about
four months learning all that yeah it
was it was pre-recorded by a great jazz
pianist named Randy Kerber and then Ryan
took those recordings and sheet music
we transcribed everything on a sheet
music or it was in sheet music before
Randy played and then Ryan studied it
for four months and learned every single
note of it and yeah what you see in the
movie there are no hand doubles there's
no CGI it's all Ryan we almost had a
hand double we had like a hand double at
the ready you know I thought I thought I
mean you always at least four little
insert your stuff I thought Ryan I mean
I just was assuming and and then I went
into Ryan's Ryan's piano room a few days
before shooting and he was just he was
playing so well I had to like put it on
my iphone his film that showed it to the
producers and we all kind of agreed that
we actually didn't need anyone so it was
Ryan all the way through we had a lot of
complicated stuff to do so he's
brilliant yeah it was interesting
learning process were the first few
months I would say three and a half of
the four months he was learning very
slowly and deliberately because he
wanted to learn every single note so
we'd see him practice and it would be
very deliberate and then in the final
two weeks once he knew the notes he just
let it all go and he acted it and the
gestures were big and flamboyant or
whatever it had to be dramatically for
the scene thank you to all of you
[Applause]
thank you so much thank you guys